[Applaudissements]
bonsoir des enfants bonsoir
bien sûr mon métier t-il le nours mon
échelle salle et répliques de poussière
et bien la wla excellente idée
je descends la lave et rendez moi un
petit service pack 1 dès que je serai en
bas vous me lancerai attendaient une
hausse
merci je peux la lancée ça y'est patron
a les yeux et me voilà merci à tout de
suite oui c'est bon soin de mes chiens
elle est encore que ça ne la touchez pas
elle est sale
je vais là la vue mafia oui à la salle
de bains chicala on va laver l'échelle
fallait une brasse et de la poudre de
savon mais de méchants lavabo dans le
lavabo dont le lavabo voudrais bien
savoir où avec un désordre par l eau
vous voyez que c'est comme ça qu'on fait
de l'or ma parole
c'est navrant je suis déçu
à vol de lons une salle thomas dans un
tel des jambes mais on envoie tout
voleur tu peux mettre dans les chaînes
je te fais couler de l'eau oui les
enfants qui ont de l'ordre quand ils ont
fini de jouer ils rangent leur joie oui
un peu de savon fa pas de mettre en
colère en gros nous je ne me mets pas en
colère
roller je suis en colère ou autres
honneurs de toner tron j'étais petit
j'avais de l'ordre moi j'en ai toujours
au palais je rangerai tour
et ma soeur et mia quelle petite fille
ordonné cette envie allez nous voir
notre maman le new gros des jamais vous
entendez ce que je vous dis fais pas de
bruit nicollin je crois que nous nous
c'est vraiment colère gagne et apprenez
dort bien pâlots vous m'avez entendu
vous ne laisserait plus de défendre ses
premiers premier juré nounours bon alors
bonne nuit
le petit la jette à la lumière en une
manche
panique chez nous à guesnain fêtes de
bourg petit diable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux monter nounours
ton échelle est bien attaché me revoilà
patronne allons en route
bonnut des enfants
suivez bien les conseils de nounours
de l'ordre toujours de l'ordre soyez
tranquilles ils ont bien compris et moi
je ne suis plus en colère je suis
content car mon échelle et propre dans
me and north bonne nuit les petits
faites de boue re vous
[Musique]